republican voters in ohio have chosen
j.d vance the candidate endorsed by
former president trump in a closely
watched senate primary
i have absolutely got to thank
the 45th
the president of the united states
donald j trump they wanted to write a
story that this campaign would be the
death of donald trump's america first
agenda ladies and gentlemen it ain't the
death of the america first agenda
robert costa costa's in cincinnati with
the results now bob vance was behind in
the polls before trump's endorsement so
does this mean he needs to send mr trump
some flowers or a fruit basket and what
if anything doesn't tell you about the
other races
maybe a fruit basket's in the mail maybe
some cincinnati chile from this great
city here in ohio but dale trump
endorsed candidates across the country
they were closely watching ohio last
night for clues about their own
political fates would the trump
endorsement be enough to carry vance
across the finish line it was it shows
trump still has significant sway within
the republican party it helped him to
repair past wounds he had following his
criticism of trump
years ago but every race has its own
dynamics there are no guarantees in
politics and trump will continue to be
tested in the coming weeks including in
pennsylvania where dr mehmet oz the
television personality is in a
competitive race a senate primary in the
keystone state and gail all of these
races
whether they're primaries competitive or
not will tell us a lot about the gop
this year as the november midterm
elections near
all eyes on pennsylvania now bob when is
the pennsylvania race with mehmed oz and
dave mccormick
oh justin just in a couple weeks we'll
be heading there next and talking to you
then
all right robert thank you always good
to see you thanks